Hello, welcome to Smart List. I am Jason Bateman, one of the less smart hosts. Even less smart is Will Arnett and truly dumb is Sean Hayes. We each have invited, well, one of us invites a guest per week. The other two don't know who that person is. Some of it's going to be funny. Hopefully you won't cry. And hopefully you learn a little something. So let's get started. Don't threaten me with the record button. Okay. I'll give a shit if we're recording right now. We're doing a podcast and I'm having my candy. Oh, what is it today, Will? It's always Reese's. Reese's Peanut Butter Cups. God help us. Not sorry. It wasn't on the first episode. It was. It was Cadbury. It was not. I never... How many of those do you eat during
Hello, welcome to Smart List. I am Jason Bateman, one of the less smart hosts. Even less smart is Will Arnett and truly dumb is Sean Hayes. We each have invited, well, one of us invites a guest per week. The other two don't know who that person is. Some of it's going to be funny. Hopefully you won't cry. And hopefully you learn a little something. So let's get started. Don't threaten me with the record button. Okay. I'll give a shit if we're recording right now. We're doing a podcast and I'm having my candy. Oh, what is it today, Will? It's always Reese's. Reese's Peanut Butter Cups. God help us. Not sorry. It wasn't on the first episode. It was. It was Cadbury. It was not. I never... How many of those do you eat during|||0|||大家好，欢迎收听“聪明名单”（Smart Less）。我是杰森·贝特曼（Jason Bateman），一个没那么聪明的播客主持人。比我更不聪明的是威尔·阿奈特（Will Arnett），而真正的笨蛋则是肖恩·海耶斯（Sean Hayes）。我们每人都会邀请——好吧，我们当中一人每周会邀请一位嘉宾，另外两人则不知道那是谁。节目会有些搞笑，希望你不会哭。也希望你能学到一点东西。那我们开始吧。别拿录音键威胁我。好吧。我才不在乎我们现在是不是在录音呢。我们在做播客，而我正在吃我的糖果。哦，威尔，今天是什幺？总是里尤斯。里尤斯花生酱杯。上帝保佑我们。我不抱歉。第一集的时候没有。有的。是吉百利。才不是。我从来……你在节目期间吃了多少
the show? How many of those do you eat? I don't know, Sean. How many of you know that's you, dude? That's what you sound like. You know? God. That's weird because I can hear myself in my headphones. I don't really sound like that. What are you an investigative reporter and the subject is how much chocolate do I eat? I don't know. Look at his face. I would say four. Hey, our special guest, you're going to be really excited about this. Our special guest is a eight-time congressperson from the state of Illinois. What? Probably not properly said. A graduate. A eight-time congressperson? Congressperson. A graduate of Oxford University in Oxford, England. Wow. Also, a current professor emeritus at the Jet Propulsion Laboratory.
the show? How many of those do you eat? I don't know, Sean. How many of you know that's you, dude? That's what you sound like. You know? God. That's weird because I can hear myself in my headphones. I don't really sound like that. What are you an investigative reporter and the subject is how much chocolate do I eat? I don't know. Look at his face. I would say four. Hey, our special guest, you're going to be really excited about this. Our special guest is a eight-time congressperson from the state of Illinois. What? Probably not properly said. A graduate. A eight-time congressperson? Congressperson. A graduate of Oxford University in Oxford, England. Wow. Also, a current professor emeritus at the Jet Propulsion Laboratory.|||1|||那个？你吃了多少个？我不知道，肖恩。你知道那是你的声音吗，老兄？你听起来就是那样。你知道吗？天哪。真奇怪，因为我能在耳机里听到我自己的声音。我听起来根本不那样。你是什幺调查记者吗，主题是我吃了多少巧克力？我不知道。看他的脸。我猜是四个。嘿，我们的特别嘉宾，你们一定会为此非常兴奋。我们的特别嘉宾是来自伊利诺伊州的八任国会议员。什幺？可能没说对。毕业于。八任国会议员？国会议员。英国牛津大学牛津大学毕业生。哇。同时也是喷气推进实验室现任名誉教授。
Who is this? Please say hello to our guest, Melissa McCarthy. Thanks for doing just everything I'm not. It really... So it's like... I love it. Hi, guys. Our guest is the funniest person I know, I think. I think you're the funniest person I know. Melissa, to me, you are all of those things. You are. Wait, thank you. I'll just say she's one of my favorite people in the whole world. The whole world. You're one of my... Honestly. You're really doing a center part, Bateman. Well, listen, I'm not putting... I haven't put product in my hair since March 15th, and so what you're getting a chance to see is the true water buffalo. I like you with longer hair. I think it looks good, actually. It's good, too. Yeah.
Who is this? Please say hello to our guest, Melissa McCarthy. Thanks for doing just everything I'm not. It really... So it's like... I love it. Hi, guys. Our guest is the funniest person I know, I think. I think you're the funniest person I know. Melissa, to me, you are all of those things. You are. Wait, thank you. I'll just say she's one of my favorite people in the whole world. The whole world. You're one of my... Honestly. You're really doing a center part, Bateman. Well, listen, I'm not putting... I haven't put product in my hair since March 15th, and so what you're getting a chance to see is the true water buffalo. I like you with longer hair. I think it looks good, actually. It's good, too. Yeah.|||2|||这是谁？请向我们的嘉宾梅丽莎·麦卡西（Melissa McCarthy）打个招呼吧。谢谢你把所有我做不到的事都做了。这真的……所以就像是……我太喜欢了。嗨，大家好。我们的嘉宾是我认识的最好笑的人，我想是的。我觉得你是我认识最好笑的人。梅丽莎，对我和大家来说，你集所有这些优点于一身。你就是。等等，谢谢。我只想说她是全世界我最喜欢的人之一。全世界。你是我……说实话。贝特曼，你这中分发型可真行啊。听着，我没有用……自从3月15日以来，我头发就没用过定型产品，所以你现在有机会看到的是一头真正的水牛毛。我挺喜欢你留长头发的。其实我觉得挺好看的。也挺好的。对啊。
I bet it looks good. When you're brushing it out, I bet it looks good, but then when you put it on, does it have the same consistency? Right. First of all... But also when that humidity hits, forget it. It just curls up into a ball. I literally have not had a brush in this hair since I was 12. Really? Truly. That's not true. I swear on my kid's life. You have hair for like six people on top of your head. Yeah. That's a lot of it. Yeah. Nobody else brushes it out when it's on the stump. I mean, this is the zipper one, so... Oh, yeah. Not the snaps. The snaps, it takes a little bit longer. Yeah, the wind. But with the zipper, it's good. It's a sport piece. It's nice. Wait, so this is what I didn't
I bet it looks good. When you're brushing it out, I bet it looks good, but then when you put it on, does it have the same consistency? Right. First of all... But also when that humidity hits, forget it. It just curls up into a ball. I literally have not had a brush in this hair since I was 12. Really? Truly. That's not true. I swear on my kid's life. You have hair for like six people on top of your head. Yeah. That's a lot of it. Yeah. Nobody else brushes it out when it's on the stump. I mean, this is the zipper one, so... Oh, yeah. Not the snaps. The snaps, it takes a little bit longer. Yeah, the wind. But with the zipper, it's good. It's a sport piece. It's nice. Wait, so this is what I didn't|||3|||我敢说一定很好看。当你把它梳开时，我敢说很好看，但当你把它戴上时，它的质感还一样吗？对。首先……但还有当湿气袭来的时候，那就别提了。它直接缩成了一个球。我从12岁起就真的没用梳子梳过这头发了。真的吗？真的。才不是真的。我拿我孩子的命发誓。你头顶的头发够六个人用的了。对啊。确实很多。对。当它在桩上时，没有别人把它梳开。我是说，这是拉链款的，所以……哦，对。不是按扣的。按扣的话，要稍微花点时间。对，风。但有拉链的就很好。这是一件运动装备。挺好的。等等，这就是我不知道的——
know, and I love finding out more about you because I just think that you're the greatest. Nobody makes me laugh the way you do, but you graduated from high school. You went to high school in Joliet, Illinois. I did. Prison adjacent. Prison... So Dax and I shot that prison movie at the Joliet prison. I drove... We drove by the prison every day to get to high school, and my mom, whenever I would look over, my mom would always go, don't look at them. You don't want to rile them up. I'm like... I wasn't like, pulling up my Catholic spill girl outfit. I literally would just glance over. She's like, don't look at them. Go get them riled up. There she is again. Here's a dumb interview question, but I've
know, and I love finding out more about you because I just think that you're the greatest. Nobody makes me laugh the way you do, but you graduated from high school. You went to high school in Joliet, Illinois. I did. Prison adjacent. Prison... So Dax and I shot that prison movie at the Joliet prison. I drove... We drove by the prison every day to get to high school, and my mom, whenever I would look over, my mom would always go, don't look at them. You don't want to rile them up. I'm like... I wasn't like, pulling up my Catholic spill girl outfit. I literally would just glance over. She's like, don't look at them. Go get them riled up. There she is again. Here's a dumb interview question, but I've|||4|||我知道，而且我很喜欢去了解更多关于你的事，因为我觉得你太棒了。没有人能像你那样让我大笑，不过你高中毕业了。你在伊利诺伊州乔利埃特上的高中。是的。紧挨着监狱。监狱……所以达克斯（Dax）和我在乔利埃特监狱拍过那部监狱电影。我开车……我们每天去高中的路上都会开车经过那座监狱，我妈妈，每当我想看过去时，我妈妈总是会说，别看他们。你可不想把他们惹毛了。我说……我当时又不是在拉起我的天主教女校制服裙。我真的只是瞥了一眼。她就说：别看他们。去把他们惹毛。她又来了。这是一个愚蠢的采访问题，但我一直
always wanted to ask you. So now I've got you. How amazing is it to always work with your husband and turn out great stuff? And then what is the most difficult part? Do you ever just like... Because I make these stupid, fun, dumb videos with my husband, and it almost always ends in a divorce. Yeah, almost always. Oh, we can't get it. We have to go in our corners and think about our actions. That's going to be on your side too, because Scotty's such a nice guy. That's got to be your fault. It's definitely Sean. And you just storm out? It's both of us. Yeah, no, we're just like, well, then maybe we shouldn't do it. And then we go away and then we count to 10 and then we come back. We've never had... We've never...
always wanted to ask you. So now I've got you. How amazing is it to always work with your husband and turn out great stuff? And then what is the most difficult part? Do you ever just like... Because I make these stupid, fun, dumb videos with my husband, and it almost always ends in a divorce. Yeah, almost always. Oh, we can't get it. We have to go in our corners and think about our actions. That's going to be on your side too, because Scotty's such a nice guy. That's got to be your fault. It's definitely Sean. And you just storm out? It's both of us. Yeah, no, we're just like, well, then maybe we shouldn't do it. And then we go away and then we count to 10 and then we come back. We've never had... We've never...|||5|||想问你。所以现在我逮到你了。能一直和丈夫一起工作并产出那么棒的作品，这有多棒？然后，最困难的部分是什么？你有没有过……因为我和我丈夫拍那些愚蠢、有趣、笨拙的视频，结果几乎总是以离婚告终。对，几乎总是。哦，我们搞不定。我们得回到各自的角落去反思自己的行为。这肯定也是你那边的问题，因为斯科蒂（Scotty）是个大好人。那肯定是你的错。绝对是肖恩的。然后你就夺门而出？是我们俩。对，不，我们只会觉得，好吧，那也许我们不该做这个。然后我们走开，数到10，接着再回来。我们从来没有……我们从来没有……
I love it. It's my favorite thing on earth. And we've never had a fight about it. I think we always talk about whatever we're doing so much and often we've written it together so we really know it. Yeah. And I think neither one of us really has much of an ego in that way that it's like, oh, if you don't like it, that's probably a red flag and let's think of something else. That's nice. Did you guys used to write sketches together? Like how long have you... And the groundlings. Yeah, you did. So you guys would write stuff together and then you got married and then you guys started making movies and TV shows and stuff like that. And then you started working with some directors that maybe were not so you didn't
I love it. It's my favorite thing on earth. And we've never had a fight about it. I think we always talk about whatever we're doing so much and often we've written it together so we really know it. Yeah. And I think neither one of us really has much of an ego in that way that it's like, oh, if you don't like it, that's probably a red flag and let's think of something else. That's nice. Did you guys used to write sketches together? Like how long have you... And the groundlings. Yeah, you did. So you guys would write stuff together and then you got married and then you guys started making movies and TV shows and stuff like that. And then you started working with some directors that maybe were not so you didn't|||6|||我太喜欢了。这是我世上最喜欢的事。而且我们从来没有为此吵过架。我想我们总是对我们正在做的任何事情进行大量的讨论，而且通常我们是一起写的，所以我们真的很了解它。对。而且我觉得我们俩在这方面都没有太大的自我，不会觉得，哦，如果你不喜欢，那可能是一个危险信号，让我们想想别的吧。这挺好的。你们以前经常一起写小品吗？比如你们……还有“地面小剧团”（The Groundlings）。对，你们写过。所以你们会一起写东西，然后你们结婚了，接着你们开始拍电影和电视剧之类的东西。然后你们开始和一些导演合作，可能不是那么……你们并不是
really like and you were like, oh, honey, I wish you were directing this thing. It's like, great, I will. That's exactly. It was just that easy. We just did all happen in like a week. No, I actually have loved almost all of the directors I've worked with. Like, I mean, I've done a million things with Paul Feig and Ted Malfee. And so I'm pretty lucky in that way. But it was really when we wrote Tammy, it was the first time somebody asked us like, would you like want to write something? And Ben and I had already written Tammy. And we were going through all these directors and people, you know, when you meet with someone, they have kind of a very different idea of how to shoot it. And I think they wanted me
really like and you were like, oh, honey, I wish you were directing this thing. It's like, great, I will. That's exactly. It was just that easy. We just did all happen in like a week. No, I actually have loved almost all of the directors I've worked with. Like, I mean, I've done a million things with Paul Feig and Ted Malfee. And so I'm pretty lucky in that way. But it was really when we wrote Tammy, it was the first time somebody asked us like, would you like want to write something? And Ben and I had already written Tammy. And we were going through all these directors and people, you know, when you meet with someone, they have kind of a very different idea of how to shoot it. And I think they wanted me|||7|||真的很喜欢，然后你就会说，哦，亲爱的，我希望你在导演这部作品。就像是，太好了，我来。完全就是这样。就是这么简单。这一切都在大约一周内发生了。不，其实我合作过的大多数导演我都非常喜欢。我是说，我和保罗·费格（Paul Feig）以及泰德·马尔费（Ted Malfee）合作过无数次。所以在这一点上我很幸运。但真的就是在我们写《塔米》（Tammy）的时候，那是第一次有人问我们，你们想写点什么吗？本（Ben）和我当时已经写好了《塔米》。我们在接触所有这些导演和业内人士，你知道的，当你和某人会面时，他们对如何拍摄有非常不同的想法。而且我想他们希望我
to be like wackier in it. And I was like, well, she's she's kind of a mess. It's a little sad too. And then it was finally like we couldn't land on a director that really felt right. And when we got an amazing opportunity where they're like, we were both supposed to direct it at first. And then it's so complicated to do with two people that he just did it because he's the man. Sure, sure. And that's how it works in America. You guys are so great working together too. And then and the fact that you can travel with the girls too. And it's I mean, it's just it's too good. Pretty dreamy. We mean, we live and travel like we're circus people. But it's great. You hit on something really great, which is you said,
to be like wackier in it. And I was like, well, she's she's kind of a mess. It's a little sad too. And then it was finally like we couldn't land on a director that really felt right. And when we got an amazing opportunity where they're like, we were both supposed to direct it at first. And then it's so complicated to do with two people that he just did it because he's the man. Sure, sure. And that's how it works in America. You guys are so great working together too. And then and the fact that you can travel with the girls too. And it's I mean, it's just it's too good. Pretty dreamy. We mean, we live and travel like we're circus people. But it's great. You hit on something really great, which is you said,|||8|||在里面表现得更疯狂一点。而我觉得，好吧，她这个人有点一团糟。也有点可悲。最后的结果是我们找不到一个真正感觉对味的导演。当得到了一个绝佳的机会，他们说，我们俩本来一开始应该共同导演的。然后两个人一起做太复杂了，所以他就自己干了，因为他是男人。当然，当然。美国就是这么运作的。你们俩一起工作也太棒了。而且，你们还能和女儿们一起旅行。这简直……太棒了。简直像做梦一样。我的意思是，我们生活和旅行得就像马戏团的人。但这太棒了。你戳中了一个非常棒的点，就是你说，
you know, that they wanted it to be sort of bigger or crazier or whatever. And of course, you've had incredible success. I'm actually going to say something serious for once. The guys are about to lose their minds. The music first of all, did you remember the first time we met? Oh, boy, is this a serious part? I just thought about the first time we met. I'm going to see if you get it right. I was wondering if it was with Dax. No, close if you came to Groundlings. It was with somebody else. I was working with Santa Claus, Christina Apple. Is that the first? I think so. There was the first time we actually like formally met. Well, she's a real peach. Yeah. Oh my God. Yeah. So but I was going to say so you
you know, that they wanted it to be sort of bigger or crazier or whatever. And of course, you've had incredible success. I'm actually going to say something serious for once. The guys are about to lose their minds. The music first of all, did you remember the first time we met? Oh, boy, is this a serious part? I just thought about the first time we met. I'm going to see if you get it right. I was wondering if it was with Dax. No, close if you came to Groundlings. It was with somebody else. I was working with Santa Claus, Christina Apple. Is that the first? I think so. There was the first time we actually like formally met. Well, she's a real peach. Yeah. Oh my God. Yeah. So but I was going to say so you|||9|||你知道的，他们希望它能更大牌、更疯狂或者别的什么。当然，你取得了不可思议的成功。其实我难得要说点正经的了。伙计们都要抓狂了。首先是音乐，你还记得我们第一次见面的时候吗？天哪，这是正经环节吗？我刚刚想到了我们第一次见面。我来看看你能不能猜对。我在想是不是和达克斯一起。不对，如果你来过Groundlings的话，那就很接近了。是和别人一起。我和圣诞老人、克里斯蒂娜·艾普尔（Christina Apple）一起工作。那是第一次吗？我想是的。那是我们真正意义上正式见面的时候。哦，她真是个大好人。对啊。哦天哪。对啊。所以，我刚才想说的是
so people you've had incredible success being super hilarious. But also you've had a lot of success being very dramatic. You've, you know, you've been nominated for two Oscars. That's incredible. One was for Bridesmaids for it's for being funny. But the other one for Can You Ever Forgive Me that I thought was really such a, even though you were nominated, it was still a very unheralded performance. You were so good. Unbelievable. Incredible. Incredible. Oh, God, you guys loved it. Jason and I, we saw you, we spent a minute, we had dinner one night and had lunch when you're in New York. I think you were probably shooting that at that time. I think it was. I didn't realize that you were doing that and I'm such
so people you've had incredible success being super hilarious. But also you've had a lot of success being very dramatic. You've, you know, you've been nominated for two Oscars. That's incredible. One was for Bridesmaids for it's for being funny. But the other one for Can You Ever Forgive Me that I thought was really such a, even though you were nominated, it was still a very unheralded performance. You were so good. Unbelievable. Incredible. Oh, God, you guys loved it. Jason and I, we saw you, we spent a minute, we had dinner one night and had lunch when you're in New York. I think you were probably shooting that at that time. I think it was. I didn't realize that you were doing that and I'm such|||10|||所以人们，你以超级搞笑取得了巨大的成功。但同时你在非常严肃的戏剧领域也取得了巨大的成功。你，你知道的，你曾获得两次奥斯卡提名。太不可思议了。一次是因为《伴娘》（Bridesmaids）里的搞笑表现。但另一次是因为《你能原谅我吗？》（Can You Ever Forgive Me?），我觉得那真的是一个——尽管你获得了提名，但那仍然是一个非常低调且未受足够赞誉的表演。你演得太好了。难以置信。不可思议。哦，天哪，你们太喜欢了。杰森和我，我们见到了你，我们花了一点时间，有一天晚上一起吃了晚饭，你来纽约时还一起吃了午餐。我想你当时可能正在拍那部戏。我想是的。我当时没意识到你在做那个，而且我真是
a, I was such a fan of that movie. I was just, I found it to be so moving and, and Bateman so jealous that you got nominated. Don't tell us this in the interview. Look how craven his eyes are. You should see the hate mail from Bateman I get. It's intense. The voodoo doll's got pins all over it. Even though he cuts out the magazine letter and you know what's coming from Bateman. I know it's him. But, but do you, now that you'd kind of done that a few times is, and you've really got that muscle like, is that something that you're going to do more of? Or is that, is it something you even think about? You just kind of do what you want to do in the moment? I mean, ideally until I'm run out of town, which will
a, I was such a fan of that movie. I was just, I found it to be so moving and, and Bateman so jealous that you got nominated. Don't tell us this in the interview. Look how craven his eyes are. You should see the hate mail from Bateman I get. It's intense. The voodoo doll's got pins all over it. Even though he cuts out the magazine letter and you know what's coming from Bateman. I know it's him. But, but do you, now that you'd kind of done that a few times is, and you've really got that muscle like, is that something that's going to be more of? Or is that, is it something you even think about? You just kind of do what you want to do in the moment? I mean, ideally until I'm run out of town, which will|||11|||个，我太喜欢那部电影了。我只是，我觉得它是如此感人，而且，贝特曼对你获得提名嫉妒得要命。别在采访里说这个。看他那卑鄙的眼神。你应该看看我收到的贝特曼的仇恨邮件。太激烈了。巫毒娃娃上插满了针。尽管他是从杂志上剪下字母拼出来的，你也知道那是贝特曼寄来的。我知道是他。但是，但是你，既然你已经这么做过好几次了，而且你真的练就了那种肌肉记忆，这会是你以后更多尝试的方向吗？还是说，这甚至都不在你的考虑范围内？你只是在当下做你想做的事？我的意思是，理想情况下，直到我被赶出镇子，而这
inevitably happen. But I mean, I think doing both is so fun. It's like, I always kind of, it's really, I fall in love with the character. And if it's a drama or comedy doesn't really occur to me until later. Right, right. I was going to ask something along the same lines because of you're so great at Mike and Molly. And we all know that like a, the schedule and the lifestyle of a sitcom on television is pretty fantastic because it's, it's like going to the office and you, you don't have to, you know, you're not doing 14, 15, 16 hours a day. It's like we're in the office and you're the boss. Yeah. Yeah. And, and every day's half day and every day's half day office. And do you miss that? I miss, I loved having
inevitably happen. But I mean, I think doing both is so fun. It's like, I always kind of, it's really, I fall in love with the character. And if it's a drama or comedy doesn't really occur to me until later. Right, right. I was going to ask something along the same lines because of you're so great at Mike and Molly. And we all know that like a, the schedule and the lifestyle of a sitcom on television is pretty fantastic because it's, it's like going to the office and you, you don't have to, you know, you're not doing 14, 15, 16 hours a day. It's like we're in the office and you're the boss. Yeah. Yeah. And, and every day's half day and every day's half day office. And do you miss that? I miss, I loved having|||12|||是不可避免的。但我的意思是，我觉得两者都做非常有趣。就像是，我总是那种，真的，我爱上了这个角色。至于它是正剧还是喜剧，我直到后来才去考虑。对，对。我正要问一个类似的问题，因为你在《迈克和莫莉》（Mike & Molly）里表现得太棒了。我们都知道，电视情景喜剧的档期和生活方式相当棒，因为它就像去办公室上班一样，你不需要，你知道的，你不用每天工作14、15、16个小时。这就好像我们在办公室里，而你就是老板。对。对。而且，每天都是半天班，每天都是半天的办公室生活。你怀念那个吗？我怀念，我喜欢有
a live audience and I miss the people. I loved everybody I worked with on that show. We were all really super close kind of right from the get go. We just all really clicked and there's such a great group of people. I think I'd love to do something that is that format without that need for like that certain rhythm. It was really, it was really hard to, because I had never done it. And like even doing like the rehearsals for everybody and ahead of time, they'd always be like, that has to get a lot more energy. And I always say on the day, because I like save it. I'm like, well, I do a version of it, but I'll do it better. Same. Yeah. Because, right. Because I never wanted to do it full. I mean, it's exhausting.
a live audience and I miss the people. I loved everybody I worked with on that show. We were all really super close kind of right from the get go. We just all really clicked and there's such a great group of people. I think I'd love to do something that is that format without that need for like that certain rhythm. It was really, it was really hard to, because I had never done it. And like even doing like the rehearsals for everybody and ahead of time, they'd always be like, that has to get a lot more energy. And I always say on the day, because I like save it. I'm like, well, I do a version of it, but I'll do it better. Same. Yeah. Because, right. Because I never wanted to do it full. I mean, it's exhausting.|||13|||现场观众，我也怀念那些人。我喜欢和那个节目中合作过的每一个人。从一开始，我们所有人就都非常亲密。我们真的很合得来，那是一群太棒的人。我想我很乐意做那种形式的节目，但不需要那种特定的节奏。这真的，真的很难，因为我以前没做过。而且就像提前给每个人排练一样，他们总是会说：那个地方必须要有更多能量。而我总是在正式演出那天说，因为我喜欢留一手。我想，好吧，我会按这个版本演，但到时候我会演得更好。一样。对。因为，没错。因为我从来不想在排练时全力以赴。我是说，那太累了。
But yeah. And I just think if I, I don't want to do it right and rehearsal and then bomb for the camera. And you can't get that first reaction back. Yeah. So I was always like, I, I know how to cross a room and I can say the line. Yeah. So it was always, but I don't and that's where the acting comes in. But I can act it myself. No. But I would like to try it and have a looser, non-traditional sitcom rhythm. Yeah. And how and still get it like, you know, still have those same hours and still work in front of a live audience. Cause I thought that was what was so incredibly fun. Well, here's what I love about you too. I mean, you're just like a pioneer in so many ways and in comedy, just because of being
But yeah. And I just think if I, I don't want to do it right and rehearsal and then bomb for the camera. And you can't get that first reaction back. Yeah. So I was always like, I, I know how to cross a room and I can say the line. Yeah. So it was always, but I don't and that's where the acting comes in. But I can act it myself. No. But I would like to try it and have a looser, non-traditional sitcom rhythm. Yeah. And how and still get it like, you know, still have those same hours and still work in front of a live audience. Cause I thought that was what was so incredibly fun. Well, here's what I love about you too. I mean, you're just like a pioneer in so many ways and in comedy, just because of being|||14|||但对啊。而且我只是觉得如果我在排练时做得很好，结果在镜头前砸了，那就糟了。而且你无法找回那种最初的反应。对。所以我总是觉得，我，我知道怎么穿过房间，我也能念出台词。对。所以总是这样，但我不会……这正是演技发挥作用的地方。但我可以自己演。不。不过我很想尝试一下，采用一种更宽松、非传统的情景喜剧节奏。对。而且怎样还能保持那种……你知道的，还是同样的工时，还能在现场观众面前工作。因为我觉得那才是最不可思议、最好玩的地方。好吧，这也是我最喜欢你的地方。我是说，你在很多方面都是先锋，在喜剧领域也是，仅仅因为你就是
you and like, you know, I remember I also, cause you came across to America and it took you five months to get through the mountain. Yeah. And I only ate one cousin, but they were kind of terrible anyway. That's so crazy. She's a pioneer that way too. Um, because when you, when you, it's so dumb, so dumb. When you, uh, when I, I was shooting this movie in Atlanta, oh, what, this is fantastic. By the way, this is a great story. I was shooting the three Stooges in Atlanta. I heard the applause. Yeah. Thank you. Just somebody, our listener clapped and in Atlanta and I go by myself across the street to go see Bridesmaids. The weekend it came out and, and I was like, Oh my God, that's Melissa. She's still the,
you and like, you know, I remember I also, cause you came across to America and it took you five months to get through the mountain. Yeah. And I only ate one cousin, but they were kind of terrible anyway. That's so crazy. She's a pioneer that way too. Um, because when you, when you, it's so dumb, so dumb. When you, uh, when I, I was shooting this movie in Atlanta, oh, what, this is fantastic. By the way, this is a great story. I was shooting the three Stooges in Atlanta. I heard the applause. Yeah. Thank you. Just somebody, our listener clapped and in Atlanta and I go by myself across the street to go see Bridesmaids. The weekend it came out and, and I was like, Oh my God, that's Melissa. She's still the,|||15|||你，而且，你知道的，我记得我也，因为你来到美国，花了五个月才穿过那座山。对。我只吃了一个表亲，不过他们本来就挺难吃的。太疯狂了。她在这方面也是个先锋。嗯，因为当你，当你时——太蠢了，太蠢了。当你，呃，当我，我当时正在亚特兰大拍这部电影，哦，什么，这太棒了。顺便说一句，这是个好故事。我当时在亚特兰大拍《三个臭皮匠》（The Three Stooges）。我听到掌声了。对。谢谢。刚好有人，我们的听众在亚特兰大鼓掌了，然后我一个人过马路去看《伴娘》。它上映的那个周末，然后我想，哦天哪，那是梅丽莎。她还是那个——
she's like, I know you've heard it your whole life because it kind of helped launch you not that you weren't huge after Gilmore girls. I mean, you were a huge star after that, but, but I just was like, this is so incredible. Like this, I don't know, you just, I was so proud of you and so excited for you. And then in that same mall a week later, I go see the Green Lantern with Ryan Reynolds. Yeah. And I walk into the same mall that I saw Bridesmaids and there's Jason and Ryan shooting the change up. And I was, and I walked right in the middle of the scene and I'm like, Hey, hey, Jason's gone on. It's like, what are you, what are you doing here? And I'm like, Oh, Ryan, I'm going to go see your movie upstairs. Oh my
she's like, I know you've heard it your whole life because it kind of helped launch you not that you weren't huge after Gilmore girls. I mean, you were a huge star after that, but, but I just was like, this is so incredible. Like this, I don't know, you just, I was so proud of you and so excited for you. And then in that same mall a week later, I go see the Green Lantern with Ryan Reynolds. Yeah. And I walk into the same mall that I saw Bridesmaids and there's Jason and Ryan shooting the change up. And I was, and I walked right in the middle of the scene and I'm like, hey, hey, Jason's gone on. It's like, what are you, what are you doing here? And I'm like, oh, Ryan, I'm going to go see your movie upstairs. Oh my|||16|||她就像是，我知道你一辈子都听腻了，因为这在某种程度上帮助开启了你的事业，倒不是说你在《吉尔莫女孩》（Gilmore Girls）之后不大红大紫。我是说，在那之后你已经是超级巨星了，但是，但我就觉得，这太不可思议了。就像这个，我不知道，你只是——我为你感到骄傲，为你感到兴奋。然后在一周后的同一个商场里，我去看了瑞安·雷诺兹（Ryan Reynolds）主演的《绿灯侠》（Green Lantern）。对。我走进了我看《伴娘》的同一个商场，杰森和瑞安正在那里拍《换身kampus》（The Change-Up）。然后我，我直接走到了拍摄场景中间，我说：嘿，嘿，杰森继续演啊。就好像是：你在这里干什么？然后我说：哦，瑞安，我要上楼去看你的电影了。哦，我的
God. It's the craziest thing. That's so bizarre. And then you saw it. Isn't this story, you saw it and then came down, you came down and you said, Ryan, can I talk to you for a second? Yeah. After you saw it, right? It's, it's the picture locked. I have ideas. It's the picture locked. What about how I saw Bridesmaids at, even before it was in the theaters, I saw it at one of these, one of those premieres things. And I immediately, I was working on a script about identity theft where this, this guy gets his identity stolen from this other guy. I called the producers real quick and I said, Hey, I just went to a premiere of something
God. It's the craziest thing. That's so bizarre. And then you saw it. Isn't this story, you saw it and then came down, you came down and you said, Ryan, can I talk to you for a second? Yeah. After you saw it, right? It's, it's the picture locked. I have ideas. It's the picture locked. What about how I saw Bridesmaids at, even before it was in the theaters, I saw it at one of these, one of those premieres things. And I immediately, I was working on a script about identity theft where this, this guy gets his identity stolen from this other guy. I called the producers real quick and I said, hey, I just went to a premiere of something|||17|||天哪。这太疯狂了。太离奇了。然后你看了。这个故事难道不是——你看了之后下来了，你下来然后说：瑞安，我能跟你谈一会儿吗？对。在你看了之后，对吧？影片已经定剪了。我有想法。影片已经定剪了。话说我是怎么看《伴娘》的，甚至在它上映之前，我在其中一个首映式上看的。我立刻，我当时正在写一个关于身份盗窃的剧本，讲的是这个家伙的身份被另一个人偷了。我赶紧给制片人打电话说：嘿，我刚去参加了一个首映礼——
last night. It hasn't even come out yet. This woman steals the whole thing. They're like, we know what a premiere is, dude. Let's switch the role to a woman and let's approach this woman before she blows up. We can get her at a real price. We hammered her down. We got her for, we paid her $3.50 an hour under minimum wage. I remember you called me and we went and had lunch and you ordered a chicken salad. Of course you did. Boy, I'll never forget it.
last night. It hasn't even come out yet. This woman steals the whole thing. They're like, we know what a premiere is, dude. Let's switch the role to a woman and let's approach this woman before she blows up. We can get her at a real price. We hammered her down. We got her for, we paid her $3.50 an hour under minimum wage. I remember you called me and we went and had lunch and you ordered a chicken salad. Of course you did. Boy, I'll never forget it.|||18|||昨晚的。还没上映呢。这个女人把整部戏都抢光了。他们说：我们知道什么是首映礼，老兄。让我们把角色换成一个女人，在这个女人大火之前去找她。我们能用一个很划算的价格签下她。我们狠狠地压了她的价。我们签下她时，给她的时薪比最低工资标准还低3.50美元。我记得你打电话给我，我们去吃午饭，你点了一个鸡肉沙拉。你当然点了。天哪，我永远不会忘记。
Shocker. Where'd you go? Soho house. Oh. Oh. It's fancy. Gross. Really fancy.
Shocker. Where'd you go? Soho house. Oh. Oh. It's fancy. Gross. Really fancy.|||19|||真让人震惊。你们去哪了？Soho House（苏荷社）。哦。哦。真高级。真恶心。真的很高级。
How did you not walk away after that? How gross? Well, I was, I was basically just trying to get like a lunch out of him. Yeah. Did he take his salad to go? Did he take his salad? Cause I'd be really embarrassed. Did he talk, he talked, I mean, by the way, I'm talking with my mouth full of, full of, full of salad. Bayman loves to chat. He loves to stuff his mouth full of salad and then go, so. Well, it keeps it casual, you know, it keeps it, it keeps it real casual.
How did you not walk away after that? How gross? Well, I was, I was basically just trying to get like a lunch out of him. Yeah. Did he take his salad to go? Did he take his salad? Cause I'd be really embarrassed. Did he talk, he talked, I mean, by the way, I'm talking with my mouth full of, full of, full of salad. Bayman loves to chat. He loves to stuff his mouth full of salad and then go, so. Well, it keeps it casual, you know, it keeps it, it keeps it real casual.|||20|||那之后你怎么没拂袖而去呢？多恶心啊？嗯，我当时，我基本上只是想让他请顿午饭。对。他把沙拉打包带走了吗？他把沙拉带走了吗？因为我会觉得很尴尬。他说话，他说话时——我是说，顺便一提，我说话时满嘴都是，满嘴都是沙拉。贝特曼最喜欢聊天了。他喜欢把嘴里塞满沙拉，然后说：所以……好吧，这样比较随性，你知道的，这样比较，这样非常随性。
It's so gross. You really, you do like to shovel in a salad like no one else have ever seen. It's crazy, right? I don't know where it started. It's steady. It's constant. And I'm always like, it's not going to run out of the bowl. You could, you could take it down a couple of matches. It's not going anywhere. I got to eat it before it stops being cold and before the lettuce gets willty. That's the race.
It's so gross. You really, you do like to shovel in a salad like no one else have ever seen. It's crazy, right? I don't know where it started. It's steady. It's constant. And I'm always like, it's not going to run out of the bowl. You could, you could take it down a couple of matches. It's not going anywhere. I got to eat it before it stops being cold and before the lettuce gets willty. That's the race.|||21|||太恶心了。你真的，你狼吞虎咽吃沙拉的样子是我见所未见的。太疯狂了，对吧？我不知道这习惯是从哪开始的。很平稳。很持续。我总是觉得：沙拉又不会从碗里跑掉。你可以，你可以放慢几个节拍。它又不会跑。我得在它不凉之前、生菜变蔫之前把它吃完。这就是比赛。
It's the big bowl of it. I've had to witness just the, like the huge silver, like kitchen bowl that you'd. I'll eat it with a spoon. I don't care. Yeah. Missy, I have another dumb question. Yes. What, like when you were growing up, like who did you were like, oh my God, she's so funny. I wish I was like her or like, oh my God, I wish I'd give anything to be in that show.
It's the big bowl of it. I've had to witness just the, like the huge silver, like kitchen bowl that you'd. I'll eat it with a spoon. I don't care. Yeah. Missy, I have another dumb question. Yes. What, like when you were growing up, like who did you were like, oh my God, she's so funny. I wish I was like her or like, oh my God, I wish I'd give anything to be in that show.|||22|||那是一大碗。我不得不亲眼目睹那种，比如巨大银制的那种厨房用的碗，你……我用勺子吃。我才不在乎。对。米茜，我还有一个愚蠢的问题。好的。什么，比如当你长大的时候，你觉得谁让你觉得：天哪，她太好笑了。我希望我能像她一样，或者觉得：天哪，我愿意付出一切去参演那个节目。
I mean, Madeleine Khan. All the best. Like made me crazy. Yeah. Like Gilda Radner and, you know, everybody, everybody on SNL, I just was like, they're so, also Carol Burnett, like I just loved how I love that feeling of when she would do, she would do something that was so embarrassing that I would get embarrassed and I just. Did you look at any, any of the, of the dramatic actresses and, and think that that's, that's
I mean, Madeleine Kahn. All the best. Like made me crazy. Yeah. Like Gilda Radner and, you know, everybody, everybody on SNL, I just was like, they're so, also Carol Burnett, like I just loved how I love that feeling of when she would do, she would do something that was so embarrassing that I would get embarrassed and I just. Did you look at any, any of the, of the dramatic actresses and, and think that that's, that's|||23|||我是说，玛德琳·卡恩（Madeleine Kahn）。最棒的。简直让我疯狂。对。就像吉尔达·拉德纳（Gilda Radner），你知道的，SNL里的每个人，我都觉得他们太……还有卡罗尔·伯内特（Carol Burnett），我只是喜欢那种感觉——我喜欢那种感觉，当她做某事时，那件事是如此尴尬，以至于连我都觉得尴尬，然后我……你有没有看过任何，任何戏剧女演员的表演，并且觉得那是——
something you want to do? Or is that something that became more appealing to you as you got more and more sort of accomplished with comedy and just wanted to challenge something new? I never thought of, I never thought about doing that. I just loved, I really loved like the character work when someone could be someone so kind of peculiar and I think as I was so sick of, you know, really until kind of recently, most female parts were always like so perfect and so quaffed and everything was so kind of not everything, but so many parts were kind of so boring because you're just like, you're
something you want to do? Or is that something that became more appealing to you as you got more and more sort of accomplished with comedy and just wanted to challenge something new? I never thought of, I never thought about doing that. I just loved, I really loved like the character work when someone could be someone so kind of peculiar and I think as I was so sick of, you know, really until kind of recently, most female parts were always like so perfect and so quaffed and everything was so kind of not everything, but so many parts were kind of so boring because you're just like, you're|||24|||你想做的事？还是说，随着你在喜剧方面越来越有成就，仅仅是想挑战一些新鲜事物，这才变得对你更有吸引力？我从没想过，我从没想过要演那个。我只是喜欢，我真的很喜欢那种角色塑造，当一个人可以表现得如此古怪时，而且我觉得，因为我太厌倦了，你知道的，直到最近这段时间，大多数女性角色总是那么完美、发型一丝不苟，一切都显得那么……也不是一切，但有太多角色是如此无趣，因为你只会觉得，你
just always pleasant and nice and there's no bumps and bruises. So when I would see women doing comedic characters that were irritating or weird or bizarre, I just thought, oh my God, that's so much more into this day, it's still so much more interesting to me. I'm like, I don't know how to play pleasant. But your approach to your characters, it takes so much acting talent to do the kinds of comedic characters that you do and make them believable, which is what makes them so funny. I mean, so do you so then do you find the dramatic characters I put in quotes that that's somewhat
just always pleasant and nice and there's no bumps and bruises. So when I would see women doing comedic characters that were irritating or weird or bizarre, I just thought, oh my God, that's so much more into this day, it's still so much more interesting to me. I'm like, I don't know how to play pleasant. But your approach to your characters, it takes so much acting talent to do the kinds of comedic characters that you do and make them believable, which is what makes them so funny. I mean, so do you so then do you find the dramatic characters I put in quotes that that's somewhat|||25|||总是那么讨人喜欢、人很好，而且身上没有任何磕磕绊绊。所以当我看到女性演员塑造那些惹人厌烦、古怪或奇异的喜剧角色时，我就会想：哦，天哪，这要有趣得多。直到今天，这对我和以前一样有趣。我想：我不知道怎么去扮演一个讨人喜欢的人。但你对角色的处理方式，要演好你所演的那种喜剧角色并让它们令人信服，需要极高的演技天赋，这正是它们如此好笑的原因。我是说，那你，那你觉得我加了引号的那些戏剧角色，相对来说会
easier because the bar to be believable is much lower because the eccentricities are less. No, I don't think they're less, I don't think they necessarily are less eccentric or specific. I think you don't have the added thing, you can just be believable. So if you're grounded, I think you're doing it. The thing that makes comedy so hard is you have to be believable and then you're swinging for the fences. You're trying to land a joke than any joke.
easier because the bar to be believable is much lower because the eccentricities are less. No, I don't think they're less, I don't think they necessarily are less eccentric or specific. I think you don't have the added thing, you can just be believable. So if you're grounded, I think you're doing it. The thing that makes comedy so hard is you have to be believable and then you're swinging for the fences. You're trying to land a joke than any joke.|||26|||容易一些吗？因为要做到令人信服的门槛要低得多，因为古怪之处比较少。不，我不认为它们比较少，我不认为它们的古怪之处或独特性一定比较少。我觉得你不需要额外做那些事，你只需要变得可信就行了。所以如果你脚踏实地，我觉得你就做到了。喜剧之所以如此困难，在于你必须先做到可信，然后你还要全力以赴去拼搏。你试图讲出一个笑话，比任何笑话都难。
The best joke in the world out of 100 people, 60 will love it, 20 don't get it, 10 are offended. You know, it's so hard and then the show and then the Sean Hayes. So then the drama is easier than yeah, I think it's easier to be considered like that was a successful role because comedy is so subjective, even though it really I think it's I mean, you guys all know it's it's harder. You know, yeah, well, dying is easy, comedy is hard. Have you guys heard that? No, no.
The best joke in the world out of 100 people, 60 will love it, 20 don't get it, 10 are offended. You know, it's so hard and then the show and then the Sean Hayes. So then the drama is easier than yeah, I think it's easier to be considered like that was a successful role because comedy is so subjective, even though it really I think it's I mean, you guys all know it's it's harder. You know, yeah, well, dying is easy, comedy is hard. Have you guys heard that? No, no.|||27|||世界上最好的笑话，在100个人当中，60个人会喜欢，20个人不懂，10个人会被冒犯。你知道的，这太难了，然后是这个节目，然后是肖恩·海耶斯。所以演正剧比……是的，我觉得演正剧更容易被认为是一个成功的角色，因为喜剧太主观了，尽管它真的——我想你们大家也都知道，它更难。你知道的，嗯，死容易，活（喜剧）难。你们听过这句话吗？没有，没有。
And so, so no, and nobody's heard that and nobody wants to hear it. Do you think there's any knowing how hard it is to land a joke that way? Do you think Sean will ever do it? Like, will he ever let it see what I think we're going to go just right there. And I was like, this is a different show as I pull my pants up to my nipples. Wait, Missy, I want to ask you something else. Yes. Here's what's so cool about you and so amazing is like, you know, all of the acting roles
And so, so no, and nobody's heard that and nobody wants to hear it. Do you think there's any knowing how hard it is to land a joke that way? Do you think Sean will ever do it? Like, will he ever let it see what I think we're going to go just right there. And I was like, this is a different show as I pull my pants up to my nipples. Wait, Missy, I want to ask you something else. Yes. Here's what's so cool about you and so amazing is like, you know, all of the acting roles|||28|||所以，所以没有，没人听过那句话，也没人想听。你觉得，既然知道抖出一个包袱有多难，你觉得肖恩会去尝试吗？比如，他会让他看到——我觉得我们要说到那儿去了。我当时想：这可真是个不同的节目啊，同时我把裤子拉到了乳头上。等等，米茜，我还想问你个问题。好的。你最酷、最厉害的地方在于，你知道的，所有的演艺角色
and all the accolades and then you go on and you'll be this producer and this unbelievable producer that, you know, like what made you want to do that and and it's it is kind of so inspiring. And you are such like you seem to me, although we've never worked together and I hope we do one day. I know. Isn't that odd? Isn't that crazy?
and all the accolades and then you go on and you'll be this producer and this unbelievable producer that, you know, like what made you want to do that and and it's it is kind of so inspiring. And you are such like you seem to me, although we've never worked together and I hope we do one day. I know. Isn't that odd? Isn't that crazy?|||29|||和所有的赞誉，然后你继续前进，成为了一名制片人，一个令人难以置信的制片人，你知道的，是什么让你想这么做的？这真的挺鼓舞人心的。而且你真的是——在我看来，尽管我们从未合作过，但我希望有一天我们能合作。我知道。不是很奇怪吗？不是很疯狂吗？
I feel like in my heart we have so but so like what made you want to do it? Because to me, you seem like you'd be the most incredible boss. You'd be like respectful and a monster. No, you're not. Only to those who deserve it. Right, Melissa? It's true. If you deserve it, you'll you'll get it.
I feel like in my heart we have so but so like what made you want to do it? Because to me, you seem like you'd be the most incredible boss. You'd be like respectful and a monster. No, you're not. Only to those who deserve it. Right, Melissa? It's true. If you deserve it, you'll you'll get it.|||30|||我感觉在我的内心里我们已经合作过了。所以——是什么让你想去做的？因为在我看来，你似乎会是一个最棒的老板。你会既尊重人又是个工作狂。不，你不是。只对那些配得上的人这样。对吧，梅丽莎？是真的。如果你罪有应得，你就会得到它。
Taste my fist. No. You know what? I think it's because, especially all the whole time I was in New York for probably seven years, just doing really just all dramatic work and started doing stand up and then the rooms freaked me out because people were the hecklers. I just I didn't want to fight people. I just wanted to tell dumb bits.
Taste my fist. No. You know what? I think it's because, especially all the whole time I was in New York for probably seven years, just doing really just all dramatic work and started doing stand up and then the rooms freaked me out because people were the hecklers. I just I didn't want to fight people. I just wanted to tell dumb bits.|||31|||尝尝我的拳头。不。你知道吗？我想这是因为，尤其是我在纽约呆的整整大约七年里，基本上都在做所有的正剧表演，然后开始做单口喜剧，接着那些小剧场的氛围把我吓坏了，因为台下有起哄的人。我只是不想跟人吵架。我只想讲一些蠢笑话。
Yeah. And such part of the comedy rooms are like, there is a guy in every single room. I never went on one night ever when as you're walking to stage, there's a guy that's like, take your top off. Every single time or like show us your blue, you know, and every single time I'm like, are you the same guy, are you the sad, lonely guy that's like, you've come here and like, you really want me to take my shirt off? Like, I'll do it.
Yeah. And such part of the comedy rooms are like, there is a guy in every single room. I never went on one night ever when as you're walking to stage, there's a guy that's like, take your top off. Every single time or like show us your blue, you know, and every single time I'm like, are you the same guy, are you the sad, lonely guy that's like, you've come here and like, you really want me to take my shirt off? Like, I'll do it.|||32|||对。喜剧小剧场的一部分就是这样，每个房间里都有那么一个家伙。我从来没有经历过哪怕一个晚上，在走上舞台时，没有哪个家伙喊着：“把上衣脱了。”每一次都这样，或者说“让我们看看你的蓝色……”你知道的，每一次我都想：你是不是同一个人，你是不是那个悲伤、孤独的家伙，来到这里，就真的那么想让我脱掉衬衫？好吧，我脱就是了。
That'll fix you. By the way, I hope it's the same guy because if it is, it's a good bit. It was it was Ben and it was it was that was that was his big move. Now I know. That's why he looked familiar to me. Well, but do you want to be because you're so good at that, do you want to do other things that where you're the boss? Yeah, I think it's also from doing so many play.
That'll fix you. By the way, I hope it's the same guy because if it is, it's a good bit. It was it was Ben and it was it was that was that was his big move. Now I know. That's why he looked familiar to me. Well, but do you want to be because you're so good at that, do you want to do other things that where you're the boss? Yeah, I think it's also from doing so many play.|||33|||这样就能治好你的毛病了。顺便说一句，我希望那是同一个人，因为如果是的话，这就成了一个好笑的段子了。那是本，那就是，那就是他的杀手锏。现在我知道了。怪不得他看起来眼熟。嗯，但是你想要——因为你在这方面很擅长，你想做其他由你当老板的事情吗？对，我觉得这也是因为演了太多的戏剧。
Like it was always like, I produce, you know, I say produce very loosely. Basically I'd pick a play, you'd get a cheap place to do it, you'd carry folding chairs up, you know, three flights because I got a deal on this theater, which is really a rehearsal room. Right. And I did that for so many years. And then even at Groundlings, like you do all your, you're responsible for your own. If you want to do a show, you have to do it to get the costume to get the people to
Like it was always like, I produce, you know, I say produce very loosely. Basically I'd pick a play, you'd get a cheap place to do it, you'd carry folding chairs up, you know, three flights because I got a deal on this theater, which is really a rehearsal room. Right. And I did that for so many years. And then even at Groundlings, like you do all your, you're responsible for your own. If you want to do a show, you have to do it to get the costume to get the people to|||34|||就像以前总是这样，我制作，你知道的，我说的“制作”非常宽泛。基本上就是我选一部戏，找个便宜的地方演，把折叠椅搬上楼，你知道的，爬三层楼，因为我谈妥了这个剧场，其实也就是个排练室。对。我那样干了好多年。然后甚至在Groundlings（地面小剧团），你做你所有的……你得对你自己的事负责。如果你想做一场演出，你必须自己去搞定服装，找人来
see it. So kind of, I think I didn't know when you started that I wasn't just supposed to do everything. And also I started on sets as a PA. So it's to this day, I still weirdly like, if somebody's like, we got to get the coffee table moved. I'm like, I'm on it. And like I'm constantly, I'm forever being asked to stop moving furniture, but it's like,
see it. So kind of, I think I didn't know when you started that I wasn't just supposed to do everything. And also I started on sets as a PA. So it's to this day, I still weirdly like, if somebody's like, we got to get the coffee table moved. I'm like, I'm on it. And like I'm constantly, I'm forever being asked to stop moving furniture, but it's like,|||35|||看。所以某种程度上，我想刚开始的时候我并不知道我不应该一个人包办所有事。而且我一开始在片场是当制片助理（PA）。所以直到今天，我依然会有种奇怪的习惯，如果有人说：我们得把茶几搬一下。我就会说：我来搞定。而且我经常，我永远都在被要求别再搬家具了，但这就好像是——
I love that. Well, I was standing next to the coffee table. I know it's like union rules, union rules. I can move the chair. It's just my, I think it's my Midwestern nature of like, same, I'll just do it. And I find it all super creative. I like all the monotony of what's the rug going to be? Where do we want to shoot?
I love that. Well, I was standing next to the coffee table. I know it's like union rules, union rules. I can move the chair. It's just my, I think it's my Midwestern nature of like, same, I'll just do it. And I find it all super creative. I like all the monotony of what's the rug going to be? Where do we want to shoot?|||36|||我就是喜欢这样。好吧，我当时正站在茶几旁边。我知道这违反了工会规定，工会规定。我可以搬椅子。这只是我的，我觉得这是我中西部人的天性：一样，我自己来就行。而且我发现这一切都超级有创造力。我喜欢所有那些单调的琐事：地毯是什么样的？我们想在哪里拍摄？
What's the location? I love the whole process. Melissa, this, the start of doing acting, comedy, what have you? Sure. What did it come from? Like looking at the, the funny acts on SNL and, and Carol Burnett, or did it start earlier than that as sort of like, um, trying to figure out who I am. So I'm going to pretend I'm different people.
What's the location? I love the whole process. Melissa, this, the start of doing acting, comedy, what have you? Sure. What did it come from? Like looking at the, the funny acts on SNL and, and Carol Burnett, or did it start earlier than that as sort of like, um, trying to figure out who I am. So I'm going to pretend I'm different people.|||37|||外景地在哪？我喜欢整个过程。梅丽莎，这个，开始从事表演、喜剧之类的契机？当然。它是从哪里来的？比如看SNL和卡罗尔·伯内特的搞笑表演，还是在那之前更早就开始了，就像是……嗯，试图弄清楚我是谁。所以我假装我是不同的人。
What are you hiding from, Melissa? It's me. I'm projecting. What are you running? Oh my God. This is the place to tell it when I killed that. No one will see you cry on the radio. You're like, if only they would call me to be on so I could reveal the true me.
What are you hiding from, Melissa? It's me. I'm projecting. What are you running? Oh my God. This is the place to tell it when I killed that. No one will see you cry on the radio. You're like, if only they would call me to be on so I could reveal the true me.|||38|||你在逃避什么，梅丽莎？是我。我在投射。你在逃避什么？哦，天哪。这就是倾诉的地方，当我搞砸那个的时候。在收音机里没人会看到你哭。你就像是在说：要是他们能叫我上节目，好让我展现真正的我该多好。
Um, no, I, I, again, I went into it like in a weird way. I, I moved to New York to go to FIT and to do women's fashion. I didn't know that. That's so cool. That's still something you pursue. Right. You got a clothing line. Yeah.
Um, no, I, I again, I went into it like in a weird way. I, I moved to New York to go to FIT and to do women's fashion. I didn't know that. That's so cool. That's still something you pursue. Right. You got a clothing line. Yeah.|||39|||嗯，不，我，我再次声明，我是以一种奇怪的方式踏入这一行的。我，我搬到纽约去上FIT（纽约时装学院），学习女装设计。我不知道这件事。太酷了。这仍然是你追求的事业吗？对。你有个服装品牌。对啊。
It's still something I do. Um, the, the first, I've always loved it. And that's what all through high school, through college, like a little bit, I went to college. I was in clothing and textiles. And um, All right. Cause you have your clothesline.
It's still something I do. Um, the, the first, I've always loved it. And that's what all through high school, through college, like a little bit, I went to college. I was in clothing and textiles. And um, All right. Cause you have your clothesline.|||40|||这仍然是我在做的事。嗯，第一，我一直都很热爱它。这就是我整个高中、整个大学期间一直在做的事——我去上过大学。我学的是服装与纺织品专业。然后……好吧。因为你有你的服装系列。
I forgot. Yeah. Yeah. And when I got there, I moved in with one of my closest friends from, uh, back in Illinois, uh, Brian Atwood, he's a great shoe designer now. And he, we got, he had a village voice and I think the second, maybe my first full night in New York, he's like, you're going and you're going to do stand up. I was like, all right, I mean, it was 20.
I forgot. Yeah. Yeah. And when I got there, I moved in with one of my closest friends from, uh, back in Illinois, uh, Brian Atwood, he's a great shoe designer now. And he, we got, he had a village voice and I think the second, maybe my first full night in New York, he's like, you're going and you're going to do stand up. I was like, all right, I mean, it was 20.|||41|||我都忘了。对啊。对啊。当我到达那里时，我和我在伊利诺伊州的一位至交好友搬到了一起，呃，布赖恩·阿特伍德（Brian Atwood），他现在是个很棒的鞋类设计师。他，我们弄到了……他有一份《乡村之声》（Village Voice），我想在我在纽约的第二个夜晚，或者说第一个完整的夜晚，他说：你要去，你要去说单口喜剧。我说：好吧，我是说，当时我20岁。
So I was like, how hard can that be? I also didn't know you were supposed to prepare for it. I didn't know you were supposed to write. I just kind of got up on stage. I had like two pretty stiff drinks. I got up on stage and was like, just freestyled. Yeah. That's what I thought you did.
So I was like, how hard can that be? I also didn't know you were supposed to prepare for it. I didn't know you were supposed to write. I just kind of got up on stage. I had like two pretty stiff drinks. I got up on stage and was like, just freestyled. Yeah. That's what I thought you did.|||42|||所以我当时想：那能有多难？我也不知道原来还需要为此做准备。我不知道原来还需要写稿子。我就是直接上了台。我喝了两杯挺烈的酒。我走上台，然后就……纯即兴发挥。对。我也觉得你是这么干的。
I didn't know any. I was just oblivious. You're like, Brian told me. And then it was, it was really fun. So I, that's kind of the whole way I got into it. Wow. Like two days later, I was like, I don't think I'm finishing college mom and dad. No way.
I didn't know any. I was just oblivious. You're like, Brian told me. And then it was, it was really fun. So I, that's kind of the whole way I got into it. Wow. Like two days later, I was like, I don't think I'm finishing college mom and dad. No way.|||43|||我什么都不知道。我当时完全一无所知。你就像是：布赖恩告诉我的。然后呢，这真的很有趣。所以，这就是我进入这行的整个过程。哇。大约两天后，我就想：爸妈，我觉得我读不完大学了。没门。
My favorite thing to hear is your best, your like favorite audition story gone wrong and your favorite, like theater mishap, like, because you said you went up and winged it. Like what was the worst? Worst audition, I have to say was I went in for like, like it was like some Western. It was like a sequel to some very, you know, harsh Western. And it was a scene where I was supposed to be, I was found wandering naked in the desert because I had been raped by like 12 American Indians. I read for the same part.
My favorite thing to hear is your best, your like favorite audition story gone wrong and your favorite, like theater mishap, like, because you said you went up and winged it. Like what was the worst? Worst audition, I have to say was I went in for like, like it was like some Western. It was like a sequel to some very, you know, harsh Western. And it was a scene where I was supposed to be, I was found wandering naked in the desert because I had been raped by like 12 American Indians. I read for the same part.|||44|||我最喜欢听的故事就是你最好笑的、诸如试镜出错的故事，以及你最喜欢的戏剧事故，比如你刚才说你上去就直接临场发挥了。最糟糕的是哪一次？最糟糕的试镜，我不得不说是我去为一个……就像是某种西部片试镜。那是一部非常，你知道的，严酷的西部片的续集。那是一个场景，我本应该……我被发现赤身裸体地在沙漠中游荡，因为我被大约12个美国印第安人强暴了。我也试镜了同一个角色。
Yes. Yes. Um, and then I'd watched like three of my three children be murdered in front of me. And I was like, despondent wandering in the desert. So I did this part and it was so funny, so funny. Um, and I did the scene and it was like, you know, it was like a full. Like you were, I was mentally like out of my mind for obvious reasons. And when I finished and I was like, I felt really connected to that, the guy goes, you
Yes. Yes. Um, and then I'd watched like three of my three children be murdered in front of me. And I was like, despondent wandering in the desert. So I did this part and it was so funny, so funny. Um, and I did the scene and it was like, you know, it was like a full. Like you were, I was mentally like out of my mind for obvious reasons. And when I finished and I was like, I felt really connected to that, the guy goes, you|||45|||真的。真的。嗯，然后我看着我的三个孩子中的三个在我面前被谋杀。我当时就像是……心灰意冷地在沙漠中游荡。所以我演了这段，这太搞笑了，太搞笑了。嗯，我演了这场戏，就好像是，你知道的，就好像是一个完整的……就像你当时精神……我当时精神上因为显而易见的原因已经崩溃了。当我演完后，我觉得自己和那个角色真正连接在了一起，那个家伙却说：你
know, some good actors, they can do something, but they don't have to overdo. They don't have to do so much like you did. You know, when good actors do that and he just kept referring and I'm still kind of like crying because I've been crying so hard during the audition. So I don't quite have my breath back and he just kept mentioning like, you know, when you watch good actors and do this. And I just said, well, I'm sorry. I guess I, I just, um, I guess if I were raped and my children were killed in front
know, some good actors, they can do something, but they don't have to overdo. They don't have to do so much like you did. You know, when good actors do that and he just kept referring and I'm still kind of the like crying because I've been crying so hard during the audition. So I don't quite have my breath back and he just kept mentioning like, you know, when you watch good actors and do this. And I just said, well, I'm sorry. I guess I, I just, um, I guess if I were raped and my children were killed in front|||46|||知道的，有些好演员，他们能演好，但他们不需要用力过猛。他们不需要像你这样演得那么多。你知道的，当好演员那样做时……他不停地提及，而我当时还在哭，因为我在试镜时哭得太厉害了。所以我还没缓过气来，他就不停地提到，你知道的，当你看到好演员这样做时。我当时就说：好吧，我很抱歉。我想我，我只是，嗯，我想如果我被强暴了，我的孩子在我面前被杀害，|||47|||of me and I was left wandering in the desert, I guess I would be more upset than those good actors because that's really what I thought. Did you say that? That's perfect. Yes. I did because I was, I was so confused. I was like, was I supposed to play it as really like and I just walked out crying and unbelievable.|||47|||而我被抛弃在沙漠中游荡，我想我会比那些好演员更加难过，因为这确实是我的真实想法。你真的这么说了？太完美了。是的。我确实说了，因为我当时，我太困惑了。我在想：难道我应该把它演得很……然后我就哭着走了出去，简直难以置信。
of me and I was left wandering in the desert, I guess I would be more upset than those good actors because that's really what I thought. Did you say that? That's perfect. Yes. I did because I was, I was so confused. I was like, was I supposed to play it as really like and I just walked out crying and unbelievable.
抛弃了我，让我独自在沙漠中徘徊，我想我会比那些优秀的演员更难过，因为我当时真的是那么想的。你说了那些吗？太完美了。是的，我说了，因为我太困惑了。我当时想，我是不是该把它演得真的很像……然后我就哭着走了出来，真是难以置信。
It sounds like a sweet guy. He was great. He was great. And then the worst theater one was Ben and I groundlings or ground, oh, groundlings. And the second we were, the site was just about to open up and then we were going to enter and literally like it is maybe within the same second that they're about to open up and Ben and I just look at each other and as if it's just occurred to us, I was like, Oh my God, this is a funny at all.
It sounds like a sweet guy. He was great. He was great. And then the worst theater one was Ben and I groundlings or ground, oh, groundlings. And the second we were, the site was just about to open up and then we were going to enter and literally like it is maybe within the same second that they're about to open up and Ben and I just look at each other and as if it's just occurred to us, I was like, Oh my God, this is a funny at all.|||48|||听起来是个大甜心呢。他可太棒了。他棒极了。然后最糟糕的剧场演出是本和我——在Groundlings（地面小剧团），或者Ground，哦，Groundlings。就在幕布即将拉开的那一秒钟，我们就要上场了，字面意思上说，可能就在幕布拉开的同一秒钟，本和我对视了一眼，就好像我们刚刚才意识到这件事一样，我说：哦，天哪，这根本一点都不好笑。
We were in matching outfits, we were in like white jeans and like yellow turtlenecks and matching curly wigs, like there was no, there was no scene written. I did. We bought like funny outfits and I knew it and, and maybe even worse, we were going to get like glamour shots as a couple and I'm like, there's no point to the scene. There's no, there's no, there's nothing there. And so about halfway through the scene, by the way, the audience was like, you guys suck. Like the palpable energy of them wanting us to go away.
We were in matching outfits, we were in like white jeans and like yellow turtlenecks and matching curly wigs, like there was no, there was no scene written. I did. We bought like funny outfits and I knew it and, and maybe even worse, we were going to get like glamour shots as a couple and I'm like, there's no point to the scene. There's no, there's no, there's nothing there. And so about halfway through the scene, by the way, the audience was like, you guys suck. Like the palpable energy of them wanting us to go away.|||49|||我们穿着情侣装，穿着白色牛仔裤、黄色高领毛衣，还戴着配套的卷发假发，根本没有，根本没有写好的剧本。我确实这么做了。我们买了一些搞笑的服装，我心里清楚，而且，可能更糟的是，我们还打算拍一组情侣写真照，而我想：这场戏毫无意义。根本没有，没有，什么都没有。所以在演出进行到大约一半的时候，顺便说一句，观众的反应就像是：你们太烂了。那种迫切希望我们滚蛋的能量简直肉眼可见。
So we were sitting up on these blocks, like posing and doing like, we just had to keep doing like zany poses while the audience like hated us. And so I flipped back. I did a black flip off of the box and I hid down behind them and I reached my hand up above the box and gave the signal to the light moves to black it out because I couldn't take it anymore and it was just my hand, my like yellow turtleneck arm coming up, doing this motion for them to turn off the lights and they wouldn't. And I looked up, I peeked up over the box and I saw that these two sweet guys in the
So we were sitting up on these blocks, like posing and doing like, we just had to keep doing like zany poses while the audience like hated us. And so I flipped back. I did a black flip off of the box and I hid down behind them and I reached my hand up above the box and gave the signal to the light moves to black it out because I couldn't take it anymore and it was just my hand, my like yellow turtleneck arm coming up, doing this motion for them to turn off the lights and they wouldn't. And I looked up, I peeked up over the box and I saw that these two sweet guys in the|||50|||所以我们只能坐在这些方块道具上，摆着姿势，做着各种动作——我们不得不一边忍受观众的厌恶，一边不停地摆着滑稽的姿势。所以我往后一翻。我从箱子上后空翻了下来，躲在箱子后面，把手伸过箱子上方，给灯光师打手势要求暗场，因为我实在受不了了，那只有我的手，我那穿着黄色高领毛衣的手臂伸出来，做着这个手势让他们关灯，但他们就是不关。我抬头看去，从箱子上方探出头去，看到灯光室里的那两个大甜心
lighting booth just laughing hysterically and saying, no. So then I had to go, whoops, I fell. Let's begin again. And we had to pick up the scene that I'd now made even longer and finish doing more poses and then the scene blacked out and we just walked off stage in silence. Oh my God. Because no one clapped. I would kill to see that scene.
lighting booth just laughing hysterically and saying, no. So then I had to go, whoops, I fell. Let's begin again. And we had to pick up the scene that I'd now made even longer and finish doing more poses and then the scene blacked out and we just walked off stage in silence. Oh my God. Because no one clapped. I would kill to see that scene.|||51|||正笑得歇斯底里，嘴里说着：不。所以我只好说：哎呀，我摔倒了。我们重新开始吧。我们不得不接上刚才那段被我搞得更长的戏，继续摆更多的姿势，然后终于暗场了，我们就这样在死一般的寂静中走下了舞台。哦，天哪。因为没有人鼓掌。我愿意付出一切代价去看那场戏。
I would give anything to see that. I would give anything. It was just awful. Tell us about your goth period. You've told me little pieces about it before, but I want it again. Did you ever go, hey, wait, did you ever go dance at Medusa's downtown? Oh my God, I was there every weekend. So was I.
I would give anything to see that. I would give anything. It was just awful. Tell us about your goth period. You've told me little pieces about it before, but I want it again. Did you ever go, hey, wait, did you ever go dance at Medusa's downtown? Oh my God, I was there every weekend. So was I.|||52|||我愿意付出一切去看那个。我愿意付出一切。那简直糟透了。跟我们讲讲你的哥特时期吧。你以前跟我零星讲过一点，但我还想听。你有没有去过——嘿，等等，你有没有去过市中心的Medusa's（美杜莎夜总会）跳过舞？哦，天哪，我每个周末都在那儿。我也是。
Oh my God, we've probably danced with really surly faces together. That's so great. Right. Totally. Would you get up on the scaffolding? Absolutely. I needed to be looked at. Oh my God.
Oh my God, we've probably danced with really surly faces together. That's so great. Right. Totally. Would you get up on the scaffolding? Absolutely. I needed to be looked at. Oh my God.|||53|||哦天哪，我们俩可能当时还板着臭脸一起跳过舞呢。太棒了。对啊。完全是。你会爬上脚手架吗？当然。我需要被人注视。哦天哪。
Yeah. I would dance. I would dance my ass off. To be looked at. What kind of intoxicants happen at this place? And Medusa's was a juice bar. It was a juice bar. What is that called?
Yeah. I would dance. I would dance my ass off. To be looked at. What kind of intoxicants happen at this place? And Medusa's was a juice bar. It was a juice bar. What is that called?|||54|||对。我会跳舞。我会疯狂地跳舞。为了被人注视。那个地方都有什么致幻剂？而且Medusa's还是个果汁吧。那是家果汁吧。那叫什么来着？
But we pounded alcohol before going in. Don't do that, kids. Stay in school. Any whippet hits or things like that? No. No whippets. Just like Boone's Farm, Everclear, classy stuff. Sure.
But we pounded alcohol before going in. Don't do that, kids. Stay in school. Any whippet hits or things like that? No. No whippets. Just like Boone's Farm, Everclear, classy stuff. Sure.|||55|||但我们在进去之前狂灌了烈酒。孩子们，千万别学。好好上学。有什么笑气（whippets）之类的东西吗？没有。没有笑气。就只有布恩农场（Boone's Farm）、艾弗克利尔（Everclear）这种高档货。当然。
Sure. Stuff like that. No ecstasy. There's no ecstasy. No. No, not in high school. None of that. Well, because Jason said goth and then I'm thinking Chicago and then I was thinking Medusa's.
Sure. Stuff like that. No ecstasy. There's no ecstasy. No. No, not in high school. None of that. Well, because Jason said goth and then I'm thinking Chicago and then I was thinking Medusa's.|||56|||当然。诸如此类的东西。没有摇头丸。没有摇头丸。没有。没有，高中时没有。没有那些东西。嗯，因为杰森说了哥特，然后我就想到了芝加哥，接着我就想到了Medusa's。
You know, like that's like crazy. Literally every weekend. So maybe you just didn't recognize Melissa because she was so banged up with her. Yeah, it looked like if B York and Susie and the Banshees and Robert Smith all jointly had a baby. The dream come true. Wow. Are there pictures?
You know, like that's like crazy. Literally every weekend. So maybe you just didn't recognize Melissa because she was so banged up with her. Yeah, it looked like if B York and Susie and the Banshees and Robert Smith all jointly had a baby. The dream come true. Wow. Are there pictures?|||57|||你知道的，这简直太疯狂了。字面意义上每个周末都去。所以也许你只是没认出梅丽莎，因为她当时被打扮得……对，看起来就像比约克（Björk）、苏西与女妖乐队（Siouxsie and the Banshees）和罗伯特·史密斯（Robert Smith）共同生了个孩子。梦想成真。哇。有照片吗？
There's got to be pictures. There's not that many because we didn't photograph ourselves every second because it was like, I would say 16-ish, 17-18 and then like through my first two years of college, like, super like full, full length, like black cloaks, huge platforms when no one wore platforms and I was like, can I get rubber stacked on to make me even taller and just total kabuki? Like black hair. But isn't that, isn't that so hilarious? I have so few photos from 17 to 25, so few of myself.
There's got to be pictures. There's not that many because we didn't photograph ourselves every second because it was like, I would say 16-ish, 17-18 and then like through my first two years of college, like, super like full, full length, like black cloaks, huge platforms when no one wore platforms and I was like, can I get rubber stacked on to make me even taller and just total kabuki? Like black hair. But isn't that, isn't that so hilarious? I have so few photos from 17 to 25, so few of myself.|||58|||肯定有照片。没那么多，因为我们没有每分每秒都给自己拍照，因为当时大概是，我可以说16岁左右，17、18岁，然后一直到我大学前两年，就像是，超级夸张的全身照，黑色斗篷，巨大的松糕鞋——当时根本没人穿松糕鞋，而我的反应是：我能把橡胶鞋底叠得更高来让自己更高挑吗？简直就是彻底的歌舞伎妆容！黑色的头发。但这不是，这难道不搞笑吗？我17到25岁之间的照片太少了，关于我自己的照片少之又少。
I have lots of other people. Oh, you do? They're not, they're not great. You're not missing anything. No. But so you, so this period of your life is fairly undocumented. Thank God. Yes.
I have lots of other people. Oh, you do? They're not, they're not great. You're not missing anything. No. But so you, so this period of your life is fairly undocumented. Thank God. Yes.|||59|||我有别人的很多照片。哦，是吗？那些照片，不太好。你没错过什么。没有。但所以你，所以你生命中的这段时期基本上没有被记录下来。谢天谢地。是的。
Thank God. And it was just me, we would like go to, we lived in gay bars and like anywhere where you could dance. I'm sure we hung out. Did you go to Berlin? Yes. How did we not see each other? I will, I bet for sure we danced.
Thank God. And it was just me, we would like go to, we lived in gay bars and like anywhere where you could dance. I'm sure we hung out. Did you go to Berlin? Yes. How did we not see each other? I will, I bet for sure we danced.|||60|||谢天谢地。只有我，我们喜欢去……我们混迹于同性恋酒吧以及任何可以跳舞的地方。我敢说我们一起出去玩过。你去过Berlin（柏林酒吧）吗？去过。我们怎么会没遇到彼此呢？我敢打赌我们绝对一起跳过舞。
Berlin is a bar, not the city. Yes. It was just like a year, a year or two ago, we were driving, I was in Chicago and I literally screamed as if we'd hit someone and I was there, I think for, I think we were working there on something and I made the driver pull over and like people were rattled because I didn't mean to, but I screamed in such a weird way and I was like, oh my God, it's Berlin. It's still there.
Berlin 是家酒吧，不是那个城市。对。就在大概一年前，一两年前吧，我们在开车，我在芝加哥，我真的像撞到人一样尖叫了一声，当时我在那儿，我想我们当时在那儿做什么工作，我让司机把车停路边，大家都吓了一跳，因为我不是故意的，但我叫得太诡异了，然后我说，天哪，是 Berlin。它还在。
And I took a picture in front of it, but they were like, we thought that literally someone got like hit by a car and I was like, no, it's Berlin. It was like the best club and the best music ever. I loved it. It was great. I can't believe it. I'm sure we were there at the exact same time. For sure.
然后我在它前面拍了张照，但他们觉得真的有人被车撞了，而我说，不，那是 Berlin。那是史上最棒的俱乐部，放着最棒的音乐。我超爱它。太棒了。我简直不敢相信。我敢说我们绝对是在同一时间去过那儿。肯定的。
Isn't that weird? That's so crazy. Yeah. That is crazy. Melissa, are you loving all this home time? Like what's a perfect day for you now that you're at home? Like do you sleep in late? Do you go to bed late?
不觉得很奇妙吗？太疯狂了。对啊。太疯狂了。Melissa，你很享受现在这种宅家生活吗？既然你现在都在家里，对你来说完美的一天是什么样的？比如你会睡到很晚吗？你很晚睡觉吗？
No. I get up super early. Yeah. I get up super early and I go and I sit out in my yard and I have like a couple coffees. You got a laptop with you out there? Yeah. Sometimes I'll listen to like a podcast. Sometimes I'll like I'll look through the paper.
没有。我起得超早。对。我起得超早，然后我会去院子里坐着，喝上几杯咖啡。你手里会拿着笔记本电脑吗？对。有时我会听听播客。有时我会翻翻报纸。
Sometimes I watch a Bosch. I'm really hitting Bosch. What's a Bosch? What's a Bosch? You hitting Bosch? Bosch. Oh, the show. Oh, the show.
有时我会看《博斯》（Bosch）。我最近迷上了《博斯》。什么是《博斯》？什么是《博斯》？你迷上了《博斯》？Bosch。哦，那部剧。哦，那部剧。
Yeah. I'm hitting Bosch like. Come on. Pretty hard. So it's like 6 a.m. I'm out there just watching. Bosch. And that's on the, that's on the outdoor TV or is it on a laptop?
对。我迷《博斯》就像是。拜托。看得可入迷了。所以差不多早上 6 点吧，我坐在那儿看《博斯》。那是用室外的电视看，还是在笔记本电脑上看？
Just on my iPad, but like that's what I'm doing at 615 or I'm like reading the paper. It's like, it's, it's one or the other. And I garden. Oh, wow. Physical paper. Do you get a paper delivery? No. No.
就在我的 iPad 上，差不多就是我 6 点 15 分在做的事，要么就是在看报纸。就这，二者选其一。然后我还会园艺。哦，哇。实体报纸？你订了报纸送到家里吗？没有。没有。
Not anymore. I love a real paper, but. Sure. Did you say garden? I'm gardening like crazy. Are you really? What are you growing? Vegetables or fruit or?
现在不订了。我喜欢真正的纸质报纸，但是。当然。你刚才说园艺？我疯狂地在搞园艺。真的吗？你在种什么？蔬菜、水果还是别的？
This just officially turned into an NPR show. Oh, yeah. I know. I'm like, I'm proving that I'm the world's most boring person. No, no. I've gotten super into things that you can regrow. Like if you cut romaine and leeks and celery, you can set them in water and they regrow. Like a celery nub will regrow a whole thing of celery.
这节目正式变成美国国家公共电台（NPR）的节目了。哦，对。我知道。我简直是在证明我是世界上最无聊的人。不，不。我迷上了那种可以重新生长植物。比如你把罗曼生菜、韭葱和芹菜切下来，把它们泡在水里，它们就能重新长出来。就像一个芹菜根就能重新长出一整棵芹菜。
Oh, I'm into that. Really? And they keep doing it. And I'm fascinated with it. I have like 20 growing around my yard and I have, you know, tomatoes and artichokes. I'm doing that with my organs. I'm doing that with my organs in the bathroom. I'm doing that.
哦，我对这个很感兴趣。真的吗？而且它们会一直长。我对此着迷得不行。我院子里大概种了 20 个，我还有番茄和洋蓟。我在洗手间里用我的内脏也在干这事。我在做这个。
Listen, Bateman. This is a little tip of it in a dish. Just tell Bateman what you're going and he'll crack that window behind him and yell at his gardeners to grow the same thing and you guys will have the same stuff. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Now are you taking these vegetables to farmers market or are you cooking them?
听着，Bateman。这只是一个小窍门，放在盘子里。你只要告诉 Bateman 你在种什么，他就会摇下身后的窗户，对他的园丁大喊让他们种一样的东西，你们俩就能种出一样的东西了。对。对。对。话说你会把这些蔬菜拿到农夫市集去卖，还是自己煮来吃？
Yeah. Yeah. She's out in Brentwood every Saturday for six hours, Bateman. Come on down. Go fuck yourself, Bateman. Jesus Christ. And I bargain hard. Yeah.
对。对。她每个星期六都在布伦特伍德（Brentwood）待六个小时，Bateman。快来吧。去你妈的，Bateman。天呐。而且我还砍价砍得很凶。 yeah。
Are the girls helping you or are they making fun of you? No, they make fun of me. They make fun of me. And like every time I bring in, I'm like, look, this is a bowl of strawberries from art. They're like, that's great. Yeah. And we grew these.
孩子们会帮你还是取笑你？不，她们取笑我。她们取笑我。而且每次我拿东西进来，我都说，看，这是一碗从艺术品（这里指自己种的成果）里摘的草莓。她们就说，太棒了。对。我们自己种的。
Like I grew these for you and they're like, yeah, okay. Now Melissa McCarthy, do you, do your children show any signs of wanting to do what mom and dad does? I think so. I don't know if they want to admit it like Viv, my 13 year old, she played me in something that we just filmed and she had like a pretty sizable part in it. So good. And it was so, and she's, she was really like strangely good.
就像是我为你们种的，然后她们说，行吧，好吧。那么 Melissa McCarthy，你的孩子们有表现出想做爸爸妈妈这一行的迹象吗？我想是的。我不知道她们是不是想承认，比如 Viv，我 13 岁的女儿，在我们刚拍完的一部作品里演了我年轻的时候，她在里面戏份还挺重的。演得真好。而且，而且她真的，她出奇地好。
Like I was so nervous to be like, I don't want her to feel pressured and like, what are we doing? And leading up to it, I was like, oh my God, I'm ruining, like, what are we doing? I mean, she said we would never let them do anything until they were like an adult. And she really wanted to and she was so weirdly good at not trying just like, really kind of like, you could see her like, if somebody would say something to her, you watched her like hear them and then like, sometimes she would improvise like just a really earnest line back.
我当时紧张得要命，心想我不想让她感到压力，我们到底在搞什么鬼？在开拍之前，我一直在想，天哪，我把一切都毁了，我们到底在干什么？我是说，她说我们绝不会让她们在成年之前做任何事。但她真的很想演，而且她表现得出奇地好，不是那种刻意表现的，而是真的，你可以看出她那种状态，如果有人对她说点什么，你会看到她听进去别人的话，然后有时候她会即兴回一句非常真诚的台词。
And I was like, what is going on? Like people were like, holy God. I asked her if she wants to do more and she's like, I don't know. I don't know. And then my little one's like, yes, she wants to be an actor and a chiropractor. There are a lot of those in LA. There's a lot. Diamond doesn't.
当时我就想，这到底是怎么回事？大家都惊呼，天呐。我问她想不想演更多，她说，我不知道。我不知道。然后我的小女儿就说，想，她想当演员和脊椎按摩师。洛杉矶有很多这种人。有好多呢。Diamond 可不这么想。
What is the, what is, what is the first and strongest piece of advice you'd give to both of them if they said, yes, here I go, I'm doing it. Jason, have yours shown interest? It's, I feel like it's starting to come on. Yeah. Do you think so? Yeah. And it's probably the influence of those devils over there at your house.
如果她们说，“好，我要去，我要去演戏了”，你给她们俩的第一条也是最强烈的建议是什么？Jason，你的孩子们有表现出兴趣吗？我觉得开始有苗头了。对。你觉得呢？对。这可能受了你家那群小恶魔的影响吧。
My terrible thing. You're terrible children. I would just, I think the only advice I would just say, do, do everything that interests you and don't worry about the outcome and just keep working at it. Don't expect, don't expect to work. Period. Just do the work. Yeah.
我那糟糕的事。你那些糟糕的孩子。我只想说，我觉得唯一的建议就是，去做所有你感兴趣的事，不要担心结果，只管继续努力。不要期待，不要期待有工作。就这句。只管努力工作。对。
Do the work and the job will come later, but right. Yeah. What terrible advice. What terrible fucking advice. I say, expect everything. The world owes you a living and expect it. Yeah. Yeah.
努力工作，工作自然会找上门，但是。对。多糟糕的建议啊。这到底是什么狗屁建议。我说，什么都要期待。世界欠你谋生的一碗饭，你就该理所当然地期待。对。对。
And get a shorter short. Yeah. Get a shorter short. Tand up and get a shorter short, girls. The only thing that should be shorter than your shorts is your fuse. Have a real short fuse. I was waiting and I was like, what should be shorter than? It's a real powder keg over here all the time.
然后穿更短的短裤。对。穿更短的短裤。站起来，穿更短的短裤，女孩们。唯一比你们短裤还要短的东西，就是你们的脾气。脾气一定要特别火爆。我刚才在等，然后心想，什么应该比……这里随时都是个火药桶。
I got four boys now as well. Oh my God. Yeah. And it's a, it's a real. It's a real powder keg over here. Are you getting up? Are you helpful? Yes.
我现在也有四个男孩了。天呐。对，这真是个。这真是一个火药桶。你起来了吗？你有帮忙吗？有。
Don't I look helpful? No. No. It looks like you. You don't. Are you for real? You look like you've been sleeping since noon. No.
我看起来不像在帮忙吗？没有。没有。你看起来像。你一点也没有。你认真的吗？你看起来就像从中午一直睡到现在。没有。
I know I look like I do, but these guys know I am a very, uh, hands on. Yeah. Yeah. It makes us all look bad. Really? I am, I am, I am literally 11 year in a row dad of the year. It's true. It's true.
我知道我看起来是那样，但我这些朋友都知道我是一个非常、呃，亲力亲为的人。对。对。这让我们所有人都相形见绌。真的吗？我，我，我真的是连续 11 年当选年度最佳父亲。真的。真的。
I don't know how you do it. Will, do your kids show any signs about Archie doesn't, who's 11, Abel does, um, yeah, consistently Abel's really. Would you be into that? No. I mean, I can always saying we don't want them to have anything to do with it. And then why is that? You know, I don't have kids and I hear all the time people who do have kids that are
我不知道你是怎么做到的。Will，你的孩子们有表现出这方面的迹象吗？Archie 没有，他 11 岁了；Abel 有，呃，对，Abel 一直都有。你会对此感兴趣吗？不。我的意思是，我一直说我们不想让他们和这一行有任何关系。那为什么会这样？你知道的，我没有孩子，但我经常听到有孩子的同行说，那些身处
in the business don't want their kids to do the business they're doing. Why is that? I mean, for this particular business is that it's just not a meritocracy, you know, like I wouldn't, I wouldn't want my kid to, while they're young enough to, to really decide one way or the other, I'd rather them go into a line of work where a diploma, a degree can guarantee a certain, a sort of a starting salary, some sense of longevity and job security. You know, this is, uh, it's so sort of subjective that, you know, that's a good for me. That's more, I don't want the competition because I keep, I look so young.
这行的人并不希望自己的孩子也干这行。为什么会这样？我的意思是，对于这一行特别是，它根本不是一个任人唯贤的行业，你知道吧，就像我不会，在他们还年轻、还足以做出这样或那样的决定时，我宁愿让他们去从事那种凭毕业证、学位证就能保证有一定起步薪资、某种程度的长久性和工作安全感的工作。你知道的，这行，呃，它是如此的主观，以至于，对我来说，这更是，我不想和他们竞争，因为我看起来太年轻了。
I don't want to be going up for the same parts, you know, I mean, just for like, That makes me want to hire your kids so desperately. I'm going to go on a real tangent to just get your kids work. Yeah. Uh, one question I've always wanted. So you made, you made, can you ever forgive me with Richard Grant? Um, I think we've talked about it, one of my favorite, and I got to, um, sort of spend a little bit of time with him at a certain point.
我可不想和他们去争取同一个角色，你知道我的意思，仅仅是为了。这让我非常迫切地想雇佣你的孩子们。我得扯开话题去给你的孩子们找点活干。对。呃，我一直想问的一个问题。所以你拍过，你拍过和 Richard Grant 一起主演的《你能原谅我吗？》（Can You Ever Forgive Me?）；呃，我想我们讨论过，这是我最喜欢的电影之一，我有幸在某个时刻和他在一块儿待了一会儿。
He's one of the most influential guys on my career. Uh, one of the real true sort of idols I had, especially that performance in With Nell and I is my favorite film of all time. He's an amazing, amazing guy. Right. Amazing. And Marielle Heller, whom I've known for a long time through Yorma. Oh yeah.
他是对我的职业生涯影响最大的人之一。呃，是我真正崇尚的偶像之一，尤其是他在《我与长指甲》（Withnail and I）里的表演，那是我有史以来最喜欢的电影。他是个了不起、了不起的人。对。了不起。还有 Marielle Heller，我通过 Yorma 和她认识很久了。哦，对。
Um, and I've known her for a long, long time. What, what was that experience? Again, cause I know I already gushed, I loved that movie, but it was such a quiet, great movie. It was an impossible schedule. I mean, we shot it in, I think like 28 days or something all over New York. And there was something about, I think when Richard and I first started doing press for it and people were like, Oh my God, you shot that in like such a short time.
呃，我和她认识很长很长时间了。那次经历是怎样的？再说一次，因为我知道我已经夸过头了，我太喜欢那部电影了，那是一部非常安静、伟大的电影。拍摄日程简直不可能完成。我是说，我们大概在 28 天左右的时间里把它拍完了，就在纽约的各个地方。而且有某种东西，我想当理查德和我刚开始为它做宣传时，人们都在说：“天呐，你们竟然在这么短的时间里把它拍完了。”
And we're like, they, they always asked, did it feel rushed because the scenes were so didn't, and Richard and I just kept saying, Marie is so amazing. That somehow we felt like we had all the rehearsal time and all the takes we wanted, but clearly that wasn't happening because we were moving as fast as we humanly could, but she's such an amazing way of being like concise and there wasn't an extra word or extra motion and a move in that film that didn't need to be there. So we weren't shooting any excess stuff. And the way her brain works and her taste level is like nothing I've seen.
然后我们说，他们总是问，会不会觉得很赶，因为里面的场景太……并没有，理查德和我一直说，玛丽（Marie）太棒了，以至于不知怎么的，我们感觉自己拥有了所有想要排练的时间和所有的镜头拍摄次数，但显然事实并非如此，因为我们的推进速度已经是人类的极限了，但她有一种了不起的方式，能做到精炼，在这部电影里，没有一个多余的词，也没有一个不需要的多余动作。所以我们没有拍摄任何多余的东西。而且她的头脑运转方式和她的品位是我从未见过的。
I think she is just an incredible force that we know she's great. I think people, I think she will be one of the best directors ever. I agree. I think that she's an incredible director and I think that you're right. That efficiency of words and emotion of those scenes really comes through. You get it. And there's not, it's the, it's the hallmark of a great, I always say that about with now and I, there's not a wasted moment in that film.
我觉得她简直是一股不可思议的力量，我们都知道她很棒。我觉得人们，我觉得她将会成为史上最优秀的导演之一。我同意。我觉得她是一位不可思议的导演，而且我觉得你说得对，那些场景中台词和情感的高效性真的很到位。你懂的。而且没有，这是一个伟大作品的标志，我总是这样评价《我与长指甲》，那部电影里没有一秒钟是浪费的。
Anyway, um, wow, Missy, this has been such a treat having you. Thanks. This was fun. You guys are very excited to see you. We love you so much. We just think you're the greatest. I'd love to get a curling iron at that hair though. Yeah.
总之，呃，哇，Missy，你能来真是太荣幸了。谢谢。这很有趣。大家看到你都非常兴奋。我们太爱你了。我们觉得你就是最棒的。不过真希望那头发能用卷发棒卷一下。对。
If we start potting up, I'm going to, I'm going to give you a perm with my whole, I'm going to give you a lilt. Time for the product again. All go well. It's thick though. Isn't it? It's great. It really is, but I want a desperately permit, please.
如果我们开始做播客，我要，我要用我全身的力气给你烫个头，我要给你做个烫发。又到了安利产品的时候了。一切都好。不过头发很厚实。对吧？很好。真的很好，但我好想拼命把它烫卷，求你了。
We love you. We love your family. Please give them all a hug and a kiss from us and thank you for saying yes to this. Enjoy the rest of your night. Thanks for asking. Yeah. All right. Bye.
我们爱你。我们爱你的家人。请代我们给他们每个人一个拥抱和亲吻，谢谢你答应来参加节目。享受你剩下的时光吧。谢谢你们邀请我。对。好啦。拜拜。
Bye guys. Bye Melissa. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye.
拜拜，各位。拜拜，Melissa。拜拜。拜拜。拜拜。拜拜。拜拜。拜拜。
Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye Nice. Bye.
拜拜。拜拜。拜拜。拜拜。拜拜。拜拜。拜拜。拜拜。
Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye.
Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye bye love. Bye.
拜拜。拜拜。拜拜。拜拜。拜拜。拜拜。拜拜。拜拜，亲爱的。拜拜。
Bye bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye.
拜拜。拜拜。拜拜。拜拜。拜拜。拜拜。拜拜。拜拜。
This is fucking good. No, but you saw her and you go, well, yeah, like you, Jason, like you said, you're like, who, I mean, I knew who she was, but it's like, who is this all over again? You just felt like this is incredible. And she just keeps getting better and better. Yeah, yeah, I guess she was doing maybe Mike and Molly
这真的太棒了。不，但你看到她，你就会说，好吧，就像你，Jason，就像你说的，你会说，谁，我的意思是，我知道她是谁，但这感觉就像，这又是哪来的宝藏演员？你只觉得这太不可思议了，而且她还在不断变得越来越好。对，对，我猜她拍的时候可能是在拍《迈克和茉莉》（Mike and Molly）
the first time I met her. And then I was like, oh, hey, she was super nice or maybe she was on Gilmore Girls. I can't remember, but I also remember that moment of senior and bridesmaids and going, oh my God. Yeah. This is a, this is just, this is like a talent overload. You know, this is it.
我第一次见到她的时候。然后我就想，哦，嘿，她人超级好，或者她可能演了《吉尔莫女孩》（Gilmore Girls）。我记不清了，但我还记得看到《伴娘》（Bridesmaids）并惊叹“天呐”的那一刻。对。这是一个，这简直是，这简直是才华大爆发。你知道的，就是这样。
Right. And then the one line is that, what was it? I apologize, I'm not quite sure which end that came out of. Was that what it was when she burped? But then she goes on and then goes on to also has this other gear. And I found her so, that performance of hers, and can you ever forgive me?
没错。然后有一句台词是，是什么来着？抱歉，我不太确定那是从哪一端冒出来的。是她打嗝的时候吗？但随后她继续演，然后还展现出了另一种状态。我发现她，她在《你能原谅我吗？》里的那个表演，
So quiet. Yeah, incredible. I mean, so surprising. And I think, look, she's set. Good, good one, Will. Love her. Lot of fun, right? Yeah.
那么安静。对，不可思议。我是说，太让人惊艳了。而且我觉得，看吧，她稳了。干得好，Will。爱她。很有意思，对吧？对。
God, she's fine. Best. Love you guys. Love you. Love you guys too. What do you guys got for the rest of the day? You just going to chill? I'm busy.
天呐，她太棒了。最棒的。爱你们。爱你们。我也爱你们。你们今天剩下的时间有什么安排？就打算放松一下吗？我很忙。
Yeah, busy. I'm busy. Back to back. In fact, I think I'm losing you. Are you going over to Canyon or is it me? I'm going over to Canyon. I'm just going to be idling. I'll be idling in the driveway.
对，很忙。我很忙。行程排得满满的。事实上，我觉得我快听不清你说话了。你是要去 Canyon 吗，还是我这边的问题？我要去 Canyon。我就在车里空转待命。我在车道上空转。
OK, bye. You still here? Bye, bye, bye. Bye. Bye. Smart. Less. Smart.
好吧，拜拜。你还在吗？拜拜，拜拜，拜拜。拜拜。拜拜。Smart。Less。Smart。
Less. Smart. Less. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Less。Smart。Less。本期节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。